[Musique]
demain ils seront quelques 321 millions
à souligner d'un bout à l'autre de la
planète la Journée internationale de la
Francophonie la Fédération des
communautés francophones et acadiennes
estiment à 2 millions 800000 le nombre
de Canadiens d'expressions françaises
vivant au Québec des gens qui attendent
avec impatience la réforme de la Loi sur
les langues officielles promises par le
gouvernement Trudeau alors que les
débats entourant le projet de loi c'est
très on considérablement ralenti son
adoption les gens vivant en milieu
minoritaire sont-ils inquiets je pose la
question à liane roi elle est présidente
de la FCFA on la rejoint dans l'eau dans
nos studios de Mountain d'être avec nous
merci de m'avoir bon c'est très c'est la
deuxième mouture du projet de réforme de
la Loi sur les langues officielles ça ça
a pas été comme mon pensait que ça
allait aller en comité de vous inquiète
de ces 13 présentement je suis moins
inquiète que je l'étais un peu dans le
dans le passé je suis encore très
optimiste que l'ensemble des parties
veulent travailler ensemble et que
l'ensemble des parties vont s'assurer
que le projet de loi va devenir
effectivement une loi je m'attends que
par le mois de juin on devrait on
devrait avoir on devrait avoir une loi
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'il
est politicien Ottawa comprennent
l'importance de ce projet de loi pour
vous là
je pense que les politiciens certains
parlementaires si pas tous comprennent
l'importance de ce projet de loi là on a
eu des discussions avec le Premier
ministre lui-même la semaine dernière
était un entretien avec un de nos
membres et il a réaffirmé comme il me
l'avait fait lors du sommeil de la
Francophonie à Djerba que effectivement
il fallait pas qu'on s'inquiète qu'on
était presque rendu à la ligne d'arrivée
et que le projet de loi C13 allait
finalement voir le jour la défense du
français au Québec a pris beaucoup de
place dans le débat entre autres au
comité parlementaire est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que c'est un peu mis
de côté vos revendications à vous
c'est que le débat entoura le Québec au
des liens quand même avec le nôtre
jusque jusqu'à un certain point c'est
certain que dans la nouvelle loi le
projet de loi c'est la première fois
qu'on voit dans le préambule et qu'on
parle de la fragilisation du français et
que du français partout Canada pas juste
dans les dans les communautés de langues
officielles minoritaire à l'extérieur du
Québec mais également au Québec et donc
ça c'est vraiment une première pour
cette loi là mais je pense que le fait
que le projet de loi a été élargi pour
faire la place au Québec francophone
c'est une des raisons pourquoi il y a eu
beaucoup de discussions autour de des
impacts à l'intérieur du Québec
qu'est-ce que ça change pour vous
concrètement les gens qui nous écoutent
ce matin qui ont peut-être pas lu ces 13
ou qui ont peut-être pas suivi tous les
débats l'adoption de cette réforme là ça
change quoi pour les Francos les les
francophones et les Acadiens qui vivent
je pense que cette ce nouveau projet de
loi là va est historique dans le sens
que justement on parle de la
fragilisation du français on donne la
place aussi à des mesures positives
quand les gouvernements si ça demeure
comme comme c'est maintenant avec les
travaux du comité par exemple quand
les le fédéral va discuter va négocier
des entrantes fédérales provinciales
territoriales avec les provinces et
territoires ils devront s'assurer qu'on
parle des communautés de langue
officielles francophones en région
minoritaire et ils devront faire des
consultations pour voir comment mieux
répondre aux besoins des communautés et
il y a également plusieurs autres
éléments si je pense si je prends aussi
par exemple tout ce qui touche
l'immigration francophone dans le projet
de loi
on parle de l'importance de
l'immigration francophone pour rétablir
le poids démographique de nos régions et
aussi on parle de la mise en place d'une
politique
sur l'immigration francophone chose qui
n'existe pas encore
tel que décrits dans la loi ça fait que
ça c'est très important Paris
immigration
pour assurer la survie des communautés
francophones à travers le pays la CFA
estime que ça prendrait un niveau
d'immigration 12% en termes d'immigrants
francophones l'année dernière le Canada
se félicitait d'avoir atteint la cible
de
4,4%, c'est loin de ce que vous estimez
nécessaire comment le Canada peut
arriver à ce type là que vous la cible
de 12% donc vous avez
la cible de 12% c'est pour rétablir le
poids démographique à ce qu'il était et
maintenir et rétablir et aussi commencer
à avoir des améliorations au niveau du
poids démographique présentement et on a
vu avec le dernier recensement comment
est-ce que les régions ont diminué au
niveau du poids démographique donc oui
effectivement ça a été très difficile
pour le gouvernement d'arriver au 4,4%
et nous ce qu'on préconise c'est 12%. le
12 % si on regarde les chiffres c'est
environ 50 000 personnes qu'il faudra
aller chercher par année dans nos
régions quand on regarde c'est l'Afrique
francophone qui est un des bassins qui
va devenir d'ici 2050 le bassin
francophone le plus important sur la
planète donc il faut avoir des
programmes spéciaux de recrutement et
qui peuvent faire en sorte qu'on est
capable d'aller dans les régions à
caractère francophone pour effectuer ce
recrutement là pour nos régions
mais on va surveiller l'évolution du
débat autour de ces 13 attentivement il
y a le roi présidente de la Fédération
des communautés francophones et
acadiennes du Canada merci d'avoir été
des nôtres merci de votre intérêt